one of the things that I always do
because my anxiety kicks up at night you
know daytime I feel great I'll wake up
I'm a morning guy when I go to bed what
I would do is just kind of say you know
Chris
all right we're lying in bed look
there's nothing we can do right now
there's nothing to be done about this
there's no actual action I can take so
let's just um let's give up we'll go on
a little vacation all these problems
will be here tomorrow morning it's just
a matter of saying you know what let's
just go on a little vacation from these
thoughts just for a minute just for a
minute and then just keep extending that
minute before you know it that's that
who you are that's like when those
thoughts quiet down okay we're not our
thoughts are we our thoughts are just
this like noise in our head and
nine times out of ten it's not helpful
yeah so yeah just practicing talking
your brain into the practice of just
being quiet you'll start to inevitably
realize this is effective